[Musique]
bonsoir il va se passer maintenant
j'entends à l'instant de jean marie
bigard au site
c'était le mec à voir aujourd'hui la
maison parlent avec ses déclarations sur
delphine ernotte
et voilà et j'ai jamais compris ce que
j'adore je n'ai jamais compris td bank
je suis paquet légumes mais je vous dis
ah bah non c'est d'abord quoi c'est un
tort c'est très bon vous aimez le
poisson légumes de vieux ça m'a dit est
grillé que les images des élections du
bois lors sa vie quand vous choisir moi
j'aime beaucoup
tu aimes bien avoir sombré h j'adore
mais il faut préparer deux égalées
[Rires]
j'ai ouvert ma blague que je fais tout
le temps parce que eh bien vous savez
qu'à la grosse rigolade bien sûr pendant
les prochains c'est un oeuf kiwis sont
dans un frigo et e
ja ja l'offre qui dit ok oui pourquoi
des verts étaient tout pour lui parce
que chaque et oui connard parce que si
vous êtes un peu le lionel messi du bled
n'importe quelle discipline peut être
comme un poisson dans l'eau que soit le
jeudi dans l'émission geopolitis
balances ton post ou bien vendredi donc
dans la grosse rigolade problème enquête
numéro deux alors c'est vrai que les
deux émissions sont tellement
différentes que c'est limite de la
schizophrénie pour vous parce que vous
passez de débat sur l'antisémitisme à
une blague sur le moustique cas une
grosse pub
alors regardez combien le sait rihanna
du jeudi est hyper sérieux prêts à
présenter le débat d'entre deux tours en
2022 alors que celui du vendredi est à
deux doigts de s'étouffer de rire hier
encore le grand écart et le retour de
cyril van damme
[Musique]
vous pensez pas que vous avez plus de
chance que jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui on faire quoi à pour devenir
président de la république
[Rires]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous s'il ya emmanuel macron
au marine le pen on a compris une drogue
c'est emmanuel maintenant voilà onidi
oubliez tout ce que vous avez pu lire
sur la révolution française c'est vrai
que c'est un spécialiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
encore très bon score pour la grosse
rigolade qui temps record un jeudi soir
et michel boujenah match oui si vous ne
pouviez garder qu'une seule de ses deux
émissions variées alors là c'est très
dur je vous lis balances ton post je
suis fou de cette émission mais là la
grosse rigolade site devenu en deux
émissions
c'est devenu un rendez vous c'est donc
j'ai fait du mal
franchement tu histoire choisir qu'une
quand même balances ton post que ccfc
plus c'est plus ses plus vieux mais la
grosse rigolade s'approcher de la disney
s'imposer mais la grosse rigolade je
vous dis la vérité en animations je
pense qu'il ya plein de gens qui
pouvaient faire s'est passé non non je
vous dis la grosse rigolade ya rien à
faire à moi j'irai jusqu'à dire bonsoir
déroula franchement donc oui je pense 6
il faut des gens et vianney c'est facile
à faire
c'est passionnant de personnes vient
quoi au déjà que les gens y viennent ils
viennent aussi parce que c'est vous ils
viennent aussi mais votre émission qui
est vraiment dommage présente ça
geoffrey très très bien communicatif
renchérir dont la terrasse est important
certes il y en a certains qui font des
bidons en parlais tout à l'heure vous
allez voir on va parler aujourd'hui et
demain de la grosse rigolade or jeudi
c'était une nouvelle édition balances
ton post ouais la seule émission de ces
vies tous les chroniqueurs ont fait des
études mais c'est aussi une émission
tout le monde s'en met plein la race
ouais les chroniques tu as les invités
des animateurs il ya un super mood
d'aller voir un petit résumé des mécènes
jeudi a tellement nouveau l'ambiance qui
s'appelle ambiance ton post comparaison
n'est pas raison
deuxième chose hormis l'excellente
oblige
allez-y
quand un gosse anglais parlerons ça y
est il est tellement choqué qu'on a
découvert les nouvelles têtes à nos jeux
des fins personnelles tout le monde à
droite donné son avis donc comme les
manifs et ça mais si
[Musique]
c'est avec nokia définitivement en fin
de toute la famille de raquel garrido
puisque après ses clashs avec la mère je
demande le père j'ai le pot américano
l'eau va pas me faire le coup detat
serait que tu le veuilles ou non j'ai
répondu à la question ça me fais tu es
en plateau et raquel garrido les
amoureuses comme au premier jour cinq
rebelles en admiration totale devant la
photo de son maître
haxhi cambiaire cueille le courage de
venir vous affrontez vous allez vous
connaissez le principe
[Musique]
et vous seriez jeudi pour une fois on ne
tient pas une armée vous étiez sous les
ca c est clairement sur votre visage
même pas besoin d'écouter la parole des
articles mais si on disait que j'avais
imaginé le cas d'un papa portant la
kippa alors qu'eux ils m'ont tous
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a glissé comme ça c'est houphouet
elle est plus sympa que sur les manifs
dans un instant avec un jeudi soir vous
inquiétez pas calgary no 1 de chirac à
la gare d'eau tous les jeudis soirs
c'est un trio foot c'est jimmy aussi
jimmy un truc formidable c'est qu'il
soumet un poids de tout le monde j'adore
c'est magnifique
alors pour finir on va venir dauphin
pour finalement dans un semblant revenir
à michel boujenah qui a éclaté tout le
monde vendredi je suis pas du tout pour
faire revenir un truc encore une
demi-heure de chroniques en attendant
c'est que votre téléphone n'arrête pas
de sonner syrie parce que tout le monde
veut désormais raconter des blagues dans
la grosse rigolade
il ya une immense star de la télé qu'il
fait tout pour venir chez vous mais vous
l'ignorez franchement c'est ce qu'on
veut c'est pas tout mais vous allez voir
chaque jour il raconte une blague en
espérant que l'embauché le problème
c'est que je pense que c'est ce star de
la télé plus doué pour se marier que
pour raconter des blagues
alors là ça c'est moi ça oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
c'est donc une jeune femme qui dit à son
père et que papa j'ai un problème depuis
j'ai épousé omar sy dépasse pas mauvais
chemin donc maintenant j'ai un trou de
balle il fait il fait 2 euros comme une
caisse il ya bon mais avancer comme en
bas bon je sais pas ça te fait faire un
euro 80 et qui nous fait chier pour 20
centimes d'euro mais c'est de la merde
[Applaudissements]
je vous invite tous les matins avocat
tôt ce matin l'avocate au sol alors
masqué ne sait plus quoi faire pour se
faire remarquer par les blagues et il a
fait installer avec sa mère après il a
fait des blagues après il a fait la
cuisine à tous frères gazon dimanche à
baba poser à poser un regard et gaz ont
été vus aussi c'est aussi mais oui c'est
plus quoi c'est bien ça rate son live à
très bientôt
parce que je surveillais évidemment
alors maintenant cessé mais c'est tout
voilà si on en parle vous avez une au
rôle de vous c'est normal à la volée
dans la grosse rigolade retrouver des
personnes connues pour être marrante
comme baffie gastambide moscato ou reem
kherici mais moi j'étais surpris de voir
carole rousseau ouais ouais
carl rousseau parce que elle était
installée à votre place jean michel et
franchement moi j'aime beaucoup les
reportages de carole rousseau mais je
m'attendais pas à la voir raconter des
blagues
commentant pas avoir géraldine maillet
complètement torche et à danser la queue
leu leu à 4 heures du matin à la salle
des fêtes atelier hambourg elle le fait
ça d'imagination j'aimerais bien voir ça
je comprends les images mais carole
rousseau et s'en était bien sorti dans
le monde de la dark axa lui a donné
plein d'idées
regardez alors déjà cyril fait tellement
démission que le public ne sait même
plus à laquelle il assiste
encore en hausse on sait pas pourquoi
mais quand on raconte une blague et
prend le vocabulaire de stéphane bern
mais aussi à limite stéphane bern et
monsieur vous n'aurez pas mon coeur et
il lui répond mais je ne visais pas si
yo madame et dont carole a tellement
qu'il fait raconté débats qu'elle a
décidé de changer de vie et de présenter
une nouvelle émission sur ces huit
blagues sous haute tension
bonsoir et une fille qui a un truc
annoncé à sa mère la manche et en simple
la mère me dit mais enfin où est ce que
tu avais la tête va dans le pare-brise
moment et la peau des retours de la
police inde en quatre tailles et on va
on va aux militaires on va remarquer
pour ses alors pour finir vendredi vous
aviez celui avec vous qui vous a donné
l'idée de faire la grosse rigolade
michel boujenah michel boujenah et c'est
vrai que c'est le meilleur pour raconter
des blagues parce que il rigole
tellement d'objets de rigoler quoi qu'il
arrive la semaine prochaine on a quand
même jean marie bigard les chevaliers du
fiel laurent baffie je pensais on va
faire une émission jusqu'à deux heures
du match de course aussi lille jean
marie bigard il a il a ramené il a dit
la ramée 28 blague
et donc c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
de passer après lui passerait quand il
raconte une blague c'est compliqué de
passer derrière alors juste pour voir je
vous ai fait un petit montage de la
différence de rire entre les chutes de
michel boujenah et les chutes de titoff
qui malheureusement vendredi était
atteint de la maladie que désormais on
appelle la chantal ladesou qui va
revenir c'est vrai des tudors qui s'est
bien débrouillé bien sûr mais vide à
broche une mauvaise foi c'est parti
alors quand michel boujenah raconte une
blague ça finit toujours par un éclat de
rire
cinq ans de mariage tu l'appelles encore
ma merveille et m'appellent même pas du
fait qu'ils avaient compris j'ai oublié
de son prénom
alors pour sa première blague titoff n'a
pas eu le même succès solution de vol
dans une boulangerie florent pagny
[Applaudissements]
alors regardons maintenant la différence
de réaction entre les chutes les blagues
de michel boujenah et celles de petite
hausse mais ces craintes continuent là
il fait qu'elle bip
il a quitté quand on se moque je parle
beaucoup c'est le succès total dont
michel boujenah le roi de la blague
le public se lève pour
regardez même laurent baffie s'incline
est forcément passé après michel
boujenah c'est très compliqué pour titan
à monsieur qui demandent à y croise une
dame me dis moi j'avais croisé un
policier sahnoun on a bon dos notre sac
[Applaudissements]